- My objective is to make
it financially unsustainable
for them to continue to
kill black people unjustly.
(upbeat music)
The film, "Civil" deals
with many meanings.
Obviously, I'm a civil trial
lawyer, a civil rights lawyer,
not a criminal justice lawyer.
I don't have any power to arrest a person
and to put them in jail
and hold them criminally accountable,
and I think Nadia Hallgren
did a very important job
showing the distinction.
- I was home in May in lockdown
just like the rest of
America and, you know,
my last film "Becoming"
came out early in May
and three weeks later,
George Floyd was murdered.
You know, as a black filmmaker
I'm just sitting home thinking
I have to be doing something.
I have to be out there.
I have to be telling a story.
This is what I do.
And I was really scratching my head
just trying to figure
out where do I get in?
Where's my jump off?
How do I begin to tell the story
of this historical
moment that's happening?
Shortly after that, the phone
rings and it's Kenya Barris.
And he tells me, "I'm
working on this project
with Ben Crump, and we're looking
for a documentary filmmaker
to basically jump in with him right now.
It's all going down and
we wanna make this film."
And he's like, "Are you interested?"
And it was just like everything
that I had put out there
and had hoped for had just came to me.
I met Ben very quickly on a Zoom,
and I knew that that was the
next thing that I had to do.
- I do want to pay the utmost respect
to Kenya Barris and Roger Ross Williams.
Incredible producers.
Roger has such gravitas
when it comes to the
documentary film space.
And then to Kenya Barris,
you know, this young man
who's trying to project
the black experience
of America on to the screen.
- All I did was pack my camera
bag and get on the road.
I had no idea what I
was getting myself into
when I joined Attorney Crump.
What I immediately saw
was just this person
who had an incredible warmth
to him, sense of humor,
sort of this personality that
I think was really unexpected
that we often don't think of
when we think of civil rights lawyers.
So as a filmmaker that really
enjoys character study,
I knew that that would really
draw an audience into him,
and his story, and his fight.
And so that was a really
important part to me
to make sure that that really shined
amongst all the other
things that he was doing,
but to stay connected to him
as a very, very unique individual.
- And watching this documentary,
it is a salute to the
genius of Nadia Hallgren.
I had things revealed to me
that I was not even aware of.
I tried to compartmentalize all of this,
and not give way to emotions.
But what she kept a lot of was
after I would talk to family
members and different people,
I would find myself rubbing my head,
rubbing my temples, and so forth,
and I never was aware
that I did that so much.
It was almost like a
physical manifestation
of the mental anguish I was dealing with,
and dealing with this tragic loss of life.
- You know, we have a scene in the film
we call banking while black,
and there's this young mother Shera Brown
who goes to cash a $90
check and gets accused
of committing fraud, and the
police get called on her.
And it's so sad, and that experience
lefts her unable to buy
milk for her babies.
When I was filming a scene like that,
tears were just falling
into my View Finder.
You know, we have stories
of people being murdered
and things like that in the
film that are also deeply sad,
but that story reminded
me of my own mother
and experiences that I've had in my life.
I just think that having
that very personal connection
to the people in the
film and the experiences
allowed me to tell the story in a way
that I hope is very nuanced
and deeply resonates with our audiences
because we know that that's something
that not everyone will experience,
but everyone needs to know
is something that happens.
- I'm often asked, being Crumb,
how do you deal with the mental
strain, the mental anguish
of dealing with such
heartache, such tragedy,
such death on a constant basis?
And I'm a student of
history so I look back at
what my personal hero, Thurgood Marshall,
said about dealing with
constant injustices.
He said, "You have to stay
focused on the mission
because if you are not
focused on the mission,
if you become emotional
and you can't be strong to stay focused,
then you can't prevent future
injustices from happening.
And so when these families
who have experienced
the worst loss imaginable,
what you are trying to do
is be strong for them too in that moment
when they need somebody to
try to help them make sense
of something that makes
no sense whatsoever."
And so I just try to focus on the mission.
(upbeat music)
- I was very fortunate to have
one of the most talented edit teams
I think working in documentary filmmaking.
We had Lindsay Utz, Enat
Sidi, and Nathan Punwar.
I had some deep conversations with them
about the experience that I had with Ben,
and what was important to me to highlight
in terms of his personality
and really who he was.
So when we went in to craft our story,
some of the first things we
did was pull those moments.
Knowing that this is a very
heavy film, it's very emotional.
And what would help bring levity
to some of these deeply
tragic stories was Ben.
We tried a lot of things, you know,
it's all like one big experiment
that one day just works, you know?
And you just hope it works
within your edit schedule.
- I'm in the public's eye so much,
but that's in my professional life
on a very specific mission.
It's another thing entirely for me
to be the subject of the camera lens.
Not just my work, but my
personal life, my family life,
and so it was a big decision,
but in talking with Kenya
Barris, our executive producer,
and then getting to meet Nadia Hallgren.
This just young genius behind the camera.
They made me feel a little more trusting
to put my life on center stage.
With all of that said,
it still was concerning
because a lot of what
I do is a safety issue,
and I'm okay with it being me.
But to have my family and
the people you love most
now become known and then possibly have
a lot of the insults or anything
was very concerning to me.
But Nadia promised me that
she would be very careful.
So I did it because I
understood the mission,
and the mission is we have
to speak truth to power
not only in the court of law,
but more importantly in the
court of public opinion.
(upbeat music)
- Ben always is talking about
speaking truth to power,
and I think for me as a
documentary filmmaker,
you know, I'm an observational
documentary filmmaker
and I think that what I hope
we're able to do with this film
is without having to add anything extra
to just what was happening
that people can really see these stories,
and the powers that be
are able to understand
more of what's happening.
I mean, what we try to
do is take these moments
that Ben has especially with families
that he's interacting with,
and show what we don't see on the news
and show the ripple
effects of these stories
that just feel like they
cycle in so quickly,
we almost aren't even
able to keep up with them.
I know that we have this
incredible global audience
on Netflix to share this film with,
and that's something that
I'm really grateful for.
The movement that
happened in 2020 and 2021
was a global movement.
We show in the film that there were people
that took to the streets
in South Korea, in Austria,
and places that you may not even expect,
but it was that global mobilization
that really put the pressure
on in America to say
you need to look at this, you
need to see what's happening.
And so we pay an homage to
that global group of people
who like stood up for us, you know,
and like connected with our experiences.
I'm excited for people to
see that and see themselves
in this film globally, and just to have
a deeper understanding
of black life in America,
and how deeply woven racism is
in every corner of our lives.
Looking at what Attorney Ben Crump does,
and like he says in the film,
"Get into the arena and do something.
We can all do something."
You know, I really encourage people
to take that as a call
to action and be like,
cool, I could do something too.
- It is my hope that people think about
the Netflix documentary, "Civil,"
for exactly what the word denotes.
Now more than ever is that
we champion tolerance,
that we champion humanity,
that we champion civility,
and being civil versus
resulting to violence.
We have to show our children
that there is humanity in all of us,
and we should show
respect to that humanity.
(upbeat music)